it's been nearly three decades since the
release of Pulp Fiction and it's still
one of the most beloved films of all
time even though one of the lead actors
parents didn't appreciate it here are
some fascinating facts about Quentin
Tarantino's violent classic
John Travolta joined the cast of Pulp
Fiction during a low point in his career
he started out strong in the 70s per
laying his success in the TV smash hit
welcomed back Cotter into even bigger
roles than films like Greece Saturday
Night Fever and blowout the last of
which Quentin Tarantino considers one of
his top three movies ever made
regardless he hadn't made a movie like
that in quite some time when he got a
call from Tarantino in the early 90s
after the success of his debut feature
Reservoir Dogs the filmmaker had the
clout to live out his dream and make his
Idol a star again that's a very kind
gesture but the way Travolta tells the
story makes it sound almost creepy
during an appearance at the Supernova
Comic Con and gaming event in Adelaide
the actor shared his tale of being
invited to Tarantino's house and
discovering his collection of Travolta
themed board games
gibralta said he just had this fantasy
of being with his favorite actor and
playing the board games from that
actor's movies Travolta being a bit
eccentric himself found the sod Behavior
thoughtful and Charming rather than
unnerving Pulp Fiction is one of the
most quotable movies ever made but few
lines have stuck in viewers heads quite
like the monologue that Samuel L
Jackson's character Jules delivers to
his victims eventually inspiring him to
leave crime behind he claims to be
quoting scripture specifically a passage
he says is called Ezekiel 25 17. and you
you will know my name is the Lord
when I lay my vengeance upon thee
you know a Biblical citation works
you'll notice Jewel speaks for a lot
longer than one verse and in fact only
the ending of the speech comes from the
source Jewels claims for it the rest is
a mishmash of all the New Testament with
sources ranging from Genesis to the 23rd
psalm it seems like a classic example of
Quentin Tarantino's irreverent mix and
match approach to writing and it is but
he didn't actually write the monologue
at all
speech actually comes from bodigato Kiba
The Bodyguard in English a low budget
comic book adaptation full of crime and
violence starring the legendary martial
artist Sunny Chiba a new narrated text
prologue was added when the film was
released in English right down to the
Boga citation it's almost word for word
identical to Jules big speech although
Tarantino naturally had to take out the
reference to Chivas character and they
shall know that I am Kiba The Bodyguard
when I shall lay my vengeance upon them
Tarantino would eventually get the
chance to work with Chiva during
production on Kill Bill in which the
Japanese actor plays the Master
swordsmith hatori Hanzo actor Eric
Stoltz appears in Pulp Fiction as Lance
the local drug dealer who supplies Vince
with the drugs that almost kill Neo
Wallace in one of the film's most
memorable moments he has to show the
Frantic Hitman how to revive her with a
syringe of adrenaline but before all
that Lance is lounging on the sofa
watching TV with a bowl of cereal in
hand the specific brand is the kind of
detail most directors wouldn't think
twice about but it was serious business
to Tarantino he chose fruit brute the
long discontinued monster themed cereal
that used to Adorn grocery store shelves
during the Halloween season along with
its more famous counterparts count
chocula and Frankenberry the brand went
out of regular circulation eight
Halloweens after its debut and was soon
forgotten by just about everyone except
for Tarantino apparently General Mills
did eventually bring fruit back to store
shelves in 2013 to haunt your breakfast
table but that was nearly 20 years after
Pulp Fiction's release this wasn't even
the first time the director snuck the
discontinued brand into one of his
movies as you can see a box of it in Mr
Orange's apartment in Reservoir Dogs
for over 25 years Pulp Fiction fans have
wanted to know just one thing what
exactly is inside that glowing briefcase
all we know is that Jules and Vince are
willing to kill for it and even though
they open it up multiple times we never
actually see inside it or get any hint
other than the unearthly glow
so what I think it is
[Music]
beautiful
that mystery is an essential part of
Pulp Fiction's lasting appeal but
Tarantino started out with a much more
concrete answer his early drafts with
Roger Avery revealed that the briefcase
contained the same diamonds that the
hapless heisters from Reservoir Dogs had
been fighting to get their hands on
apparently that was considered too
predictable so the writers decided to
leave it up to the audience it's an idea
that proved Tarantino steals from the
best the 1955 film Noir Classic kissed
me deadly also revolves around a
mysterious case and we never see
anything but a glow coming from inside
that one either we know that particular
film was on Tarantino's mind as he wrote
Pulp Fiction as he told Sight and Sound
I wanted Bruce Willis's character Butch
to be basically like Ralph Meeker as my
camera and Robert Alger says Kiss Me
Deadly
Pulp Fiction restored John Travolta's
school when he was cast as the character
Vincent Vega the man has school clothes
cool dialogue and of course a cool car
Tarantino certainly thinks so as that's
his own red Chevy that Vince is driving
according to Hot Cars the director
bought the 64 Chevy Malibu Super Sport
five years earlier with the money he
made selling the script for True Romance
it was part of the Chevelle series they
were Chevrolet's first muscle cars and
they became a favorite for classic car
fans that made it a tempting Target for
carjackers in the Malibu went missing
from Tarantino's La home the year Pulp
Fiction premiered the director probably
assumed he'd never get it back but he
did over 15 years later in 2013 TMZ
reported that the Malibu was found its
owner at the time wasn't charged which
only seems fair after all it probably
changed hands many times since the
original Thief got a hold of it there's
nothing Quentin Tarantino loves more
than dropping references to other movies
into his own in the twist contest and
Jackrabbit Slims is full of them on the
blu-ray releases Chit Chat documentary
extra John Travolta recalled that
Tarantino showed him Jean-Luc gadar's
bande par to pinpoint the vibe he was
looking for Pulp Fiction references one
of its most famous scenes in which the
main Trio danced to the Jukebox in a
coffee shop but instead of music there's
narration describing their inner
thoughts on the par obviously made a big
impression on Tarantino after all he
named his own production company a band
apart now I want to dance I want to win
I want that trophy so that's good fans
of classic movies may also recognize
some of Uma Thurman intervalta's moves
from an even more important classic of
European Cinema Federico Fellini's eight
and a half combines fantasy and
autobiography or story of a filmmaker
battling creative frustration in
existential despair he turns that dower
set up into a whole lot of fun including
a dance sequence that looks an awful lot
like the one in Jackrabbit Slims most
people probably don't notice these
references at first glance but there's
another move that Superhero fans might
notice at one point Travolta waves two
fingers in front of his eyes which is
the signature move in the batusi a dance
from the Classic 60s Batman series
starring Adam West
Vincent Vega has a bad habit of going to
the bathroom at the worst times when
Butch runs home to pick up his watch he
finds Vince waiting for him and shoots
him as he leaves the toilet later in the
film but earlier chronologically Vince
takes another trip to the John in Mrs
Jules confrontation with the stick up
artists in the diner both times he's
carrying a copy of modesty Blaze one of
a series of spy Thrillers starring
writer Peter O'Donnell's comic strip
heroine modesty was a former War Orphan
and international criminal who does
freelance work for the British secret
service Quentin Tarantino is obviously a
fan and he nearly put his own stamp on
the character at some point Miramax
bought the rights to the modesty Blaze
series apparently in the hopes that
Tarantino would make a big screen
adaptation nothing ever came of it so in
order to keep from losing the rights the
studio turned out a quickie
direct-to-video movie called my name is
Modesty variety reported that the whole
thing was thrown together in 18 days
with a director who'd only been on the
job for a week before filming started
Tarantino still hasn't shown any
indication of making his own modesty
movie but he did get a credit and my
name is Modesty as producer if there's
another monologue in Pulp Fiction as
memorable as Ezekiel 25 17 it's the one
Christopher Walken recites during a
single scene as Captain Coons he arrives
in a flashback to Butch coolidge's
childhood to deliver the boy's heirloom
watch along with its rather crappy
history it hit it in one place he knew
he could hide something his ass five
long years he wore this watch up his ass
one of the watch's previous owners Dane
Coolidge died in World War II at the
Battle of Wake Island but not before
entrusting the watch to an Air Force
Gunner named wanaki the man's name seems
like an odd detail to include so it's no
surprise that Tarantino didn't throw it
in on a whim it's a tribute to Howard
Hawks the multi-talented old Hollywood
Master Behind movies ranging from
romantic comedies like his girl Friday
and bringing a baby to film Noir
Classics like the big sleep the younger
director paid his debt to his
inspiration by placing the events of
former pilot Hawks 1943 warflick Air
Force in the Pulp Fiction World
inserting John Garfield's character into
Captain Coon's story Pulp Fiction's
non-linear storytelling was
revolutionary in 1994. thanks in no
small part to editor Sally menke's
oscar-nominated work moments from early
on in the film that seemed insignificant
gained new meaning once we see what
happens before them Quentin Tarantino
didn't invent this style of Storytelling
you can see it in classic novels like
James Joyce's Ulysses and Kurt Vonnegut
Slaughterhouse Five but he turned it
from an intellectual exercise to a crowd
pleasing gimmick in the process he
inspired hundreds of imitators from
Christopher Nolan's backwards breakout
hit Memento to the intersecting plot
lines of Paul Thomas Anderson's Magnolia
but not everyone was such a big fan in a
documentary extra included in one of
Pulp Fiction's DVD releases Samuel
Jackson recalled I remember my mom
saying why didn't they put the movie
together right it was jumping all over
the place back and forth you're dead
you're alive you're back you're here I
said Ah that's just how the movie works
Vincent Vega's name may sound familiar
to fans of Tarantino's first film
Reservoir Dogs the only named member of
the color-coded cruise Michael madsen's
psychotic Mr blunt who is also known as
Vic Vega that's more than just a
coincidence Tarantino envisioned the two
characters as brothers and wrote a whole
script exploring the relationship Madsen
recently revealed some of the details to
The Hollywood Reporter Vincent Vic would
have met up after being released from
different prisons and started a club in
Amsterdam neatly tying it to Vince's
legendary discussion of the city in Pulp
Fiction unfortunately other projects
kept getting in the way and by now both
Madison and Travolta are far too old to
convincingly play their own younger
selves the idea is still resurfaced
moving the time frame from before the
character's deaths to after and instead
focusing on two other Vega brothers who
meet at their sibling's funeral for now
though it looks like either version will
only ever exist in fans imaginations
foreign
[Music]